before today's video starts I just want
to remind you guys that I'm giving away
my main guitar when I reach 500
000 subscribers please check out
the video in the description to learn
more and now for today's video [Music]
hey friends in today's video we're going
to talk about tablature whether you're
playing Styles like pop, rock, or folk the
simplest way to get started on guitar is to
use tablature because it uses lines representing
the strings and numbers representing the Frets
so if you say go on to the first string
and play the second fret it's very simple
it's just coordinates really it says put your
finger here and now put it here and because
the system is so quick and intuitive you can get
guitarists in one lesson to learn popular songs
that might be the musical debut of Smoke on
the Water on the lute actually but classical
guitarists don't actually do this classical
guitarists play from standard notation this
is the same system used by Orchestra
players violins, violas, oboe, pianos
,Etc and in fact there's a tendency to look down
on tablature at least by classical guitarists they
think of it as two simple crude so in this video
I like to debunk that idea by showing you that
tablature was actually the dominant style of the
notation for plucked instruments like the lute,
guitar, theorbo, and more for more than 400
years so here is the history of tablature [Music]
the earliest tablature of which I'm aware
dates from the 15th century in the beautiful
heart-shaped manuscript called the Pesaro
manuscript here we can see six horizontal
lines just like in modern tablature and then
letters on those lines the letters in this case
indicate the the Frets we'll talk more about that
in a little bit so instead of using numbers like
today where if you were on the first string you
could say 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 all the way up in this
case it's just as easy you just swap them up for
letters so a is open B is the first fret c d e f g
Etc on the fifth line that's the fifth string
C on a loot we see we should play an A which
is open then we see on the fourth string a c so
fourth string a b c that's the second fret so now
we have two notes at once and then there's a third
note on the third string a b c d so we have three
three notes played together like a chord in this
case this is a a c g another C it's a an octave
with a fifth in it then we have an open second
string that's a d going to another chord this
time the same chord is the beginning with a first
fret B that's the tablature B not the note B which
makes the C minor chord so if I play the opening
of the manuscript we'd hear something like this
with some extra Renaissance style
improvisation it could sound something like
suddenly we're recreating beautiful music from
the 1400s between 1400 and 1800 there were three
main types of tablature were used for plot
instruments French tablature the system that
uses letters like we saw in the Pesaro manuscript
then there's Italian tablature which uses numbers
so modern guitarists will recognize this one
the only thing for modern guitarists that's
difficult about Italian tablature is that
it's flipped upside down so the lowest line
represents the the highest string whereas in
modern tablature and in French tablature the
the lowest line represents the lowest string
the third type of tablature is known as German
tablature this is the most different style
of notation in this one rather than having
lines representing strings and placing notes
on those strings we get an individual symbol
for each location on the fretboard I have many
colleagues who can play from German tablature
so I think it looks more intimidating than
it is this isn't something that I've spent
much time on yet so I'm going to hold the
discussion about German tab for a future video
the next question people often have is okay
tablature can easily show you the location of
each note on the fretboard but what about Rhythm
well in tablature the rhythm is written above the
tab in this example from the famous Baroque
guitar piece Canarios by Gaspar Sanz we see
a time signature of 6/8 and we see an eighth
note written above then nothing is written
until we see what looks like a quarter note in
tablet for the way it works is you play that
note value for all of the written pitches until
you see a new value so I've written out in red
the explicit Rhythm above one two three four
five six one two three four five six one and
so it's not until the second complete measure
that we have a quarter note one two it lasts
two eighth notes and then we go back to eighth
notes as we see so the melody would sound like
as I mentioned tablature wasn't just used
for lute it was used for all sorts of
plucked instruments before 1800 let's see
and hear some tablature from the past on
a variety of instruments here's the famous
Lachrimae Pavanne by John dowland [Music]
switching instruments here's a Renaissance
guitar that only has four strings in this
case you'll see there's only four
lines for those four strings foreign
moving to the Baroque lute a 13 course
instrument 13 pairs of strings you'll
still see only six lines but for the bass strings
there'll be symbols or numbers written below the
the lines representing the low bass notes
this is the beautiful Saizenay manuscript
let's see some Italian tab so this is for theorbo
but now we'll see numbers instead of letters
and lastly the Baroque guitar which
has five pairs of strings so you'll
only see five lines here's
a beautiful Grave [Music]
today people like me who specialize in early
plucked instruments instruments like the lute
Baroque guitar, theorbo, Etc that we just heard
we not only can read these manuscripts we play
directly from them in concert and I have to tell
you it's a beautiful experience aesthetically it's
wonderful to play from these ancient manuscripts
because I feel as if it brings me as close as
possible to the composer and I get the sense when
I play from it that I'm not only just playing from
music in a museum I feel like I'm time traveling
400 years in the past and playing directly from
the music that a person at the time would have
been looking at one of my goals in this video
is not only to show you the the wonderful world of
historical tablature but my goal is also to try to
convince many of you especially you guitarists out
there to learn how to read from these historical
tablatures because as we'll see soon you can
learn a lot from it and you can play directly
from it with a guitar by the way if you would
like one-on-one private lessons with an expert to
help you learn how to read historical tablature or
play Renaissance or baroque music I have an online
school called Arpeggiato with teachers who are
experts in their field who can teach you on Zoom
so please head to Arpeggiato.com and see if one
of my teachers at my school can be of great help
to you so if you're interested in improving your
guitar playing or learning a historical instrument
or even just how to play a tab on your guitar head
to rpajato.com so I really hope this video helped
you understand historical tablature and convince
some of you guitarists to start taking a look at
it and even learn to play from it next week I'll
release part two of this video on historical
tablature and that video we'll go even deeper
into the subject learning how playing from this
tablature can teach you more about the composer's
intention performance practice and how you
yourself can play directly from these manuscripts
using your guitar If you enjoyed today's video
make sure you subscribe and hit the bell so you
don't miss other videos I post like this one if
you want to help me make more videos like this you
can go to my Oatreon and there you'll find lots of
behind the scenes content about what I'm up to
the videos I'm making performances I'm giving
and you'll receive rewards like early viewing all
my videos my CDs and you can even get a private
lesson with me and lastly if you're interested in
learning classical guitar especially at your own
pace at home I have a beginner online classical
guitar course called Classical Guitar Pro it's
six hours long 53 videos so I hope you'll check
that out until next time thanks for watching!